you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 500
game against against diva chess so let's
see if we're gonna get a move all right
well this is different
b6
my plan here is just to play Bishop d3
in Queenie - right away mmm yeah why not
there could be a quick strike with c5 so
they might be lining up some type of a
hippopotamus let's let's get my F pawn
involved and then tuck my knight in
right behind so far very happy having
this trio and let's see how how they
strike maybe I even include a fourth
pawn
you
you could play bishop here yeah let's do
this first I'm not ruling out c-4 but
let's let's see what they do first okay
so I could slam the door on the bishop
let's do that now I'm really looking for
the c4 move now that I don't have any
worries of the bishop staring at my
Queen side squares playing very fast
let's give that Knight a boot Knight B
for his pawn will be pulled away from
the center on a capture I can also just
take on c5 but
see no reason to do that
you know I could just develop a and I
have to play this soon I think otherwise
there's gonna be some this is gonna be a
target long-term target let's get my
rook here I'm also doing it with this
truck so that I'm night before I have
Bishop b1 they're going pawn hunting
they gave up the Bishop can they really
hang out to this extra pawn we're gonna
find out we also have Knight d6 which is
a move no can't hang on to this guy can
you
queen f2 I could just back up both
bishops I see no reason not to do that
scoop him up and still in the end this
is a target okay so maybe some pressure
against this guy one day but still I
have b3 good control over this position
they don't have something immediate I'm
definitely liking my position a real lot
I could take right away Knight takes
Knight takes the rook recaptures and
defends c4 this is my unopposed
light square bishop so I may run into
some type of pin think clean up two
would be fine though or
you know what I'm liking maybe maybe I
just throw my knight in here
and I could track him down in a
different way be three Bishop to b2 or
maybe even Bishop 8/3 this has to be a
piece that's worth at least a rook Oh am
i falling for some trick right here I
think I might be Bishop takes pawn
I do have an in-between move though
attacking the rook let's get my bishop
on b2 you have to be on the lookout for
some type of undermining they might try
Knight B to a knight B - I'll go Knight
b5 don't want to trade trade off I fee
and cut out night so I thought they
might do that so I guess I'm going to
get a little bit of material now they're
up a couple pawns
they takes Bishop Bishop takes pawn they
have a huge Center it's not really well
advanced I could take that rook right
now but is there something better maybe
hmm
I'm tempted to just take the the the
rook but maybe maybe I could just take
here now let's grab the material yeah
follow up with Bishop takes
then rook takes Bishop isn't the
greatest piece here kind of biting on a
rock on f5 I could still insist on
trying to put pressure on d7 doubling
you get out of pins with Queen f2 if
Queen c5 but the dark square Bishop is
certainly a scary piece if it arrives
here let's see evening out on time g5 is
interesting
I feel like I want to give that night a
boot or maybe even strike with g4 hmm
they have good pieces g5 is a nice move
huh
now g4 wouldn't be so great all right
I'm gonna mix things up let's go with
the B for first see where that Knight
goes doesn't have very many options
actually yeah okay I could try to play
that night with a three or just get on
with doubling yeah let's put the
pressure on d7 I wanna get to the
seventh rank who cares about the b-pawn
look on the seventh hitting everything
they'll probably have to uh trade Queens
mmm let me give this Bishop mm-hmm
excuse me let me give this Bishop a kick
first rook takes d7 this is also
providing a new square for my king he
may want to run here one day get checked
like crazy yeah not the cleanest
approach to converting this game I think
I had a win in that middle game position
some nice control you take on b4 I
imagine and now what how about clean
right here a little bit scary Queen and
King on the same diagonal but I am
putting pressure here I'm expecting
Queen c5 bishop moves I have e6 you know
so let's see if I could win this got one
rook on the seventh
see if we could get another
tough to do because this is a really
strong night
I want the rooks off and I need to
activate my Bishop 54 seconds
I guess we'll start with this pretty
long-winded approach maybe Bishop a4 c6
and d7
or c6 and then wreck a8 yeah that could
be an idea
let's take they have to watch their back
rank if the RIP takes bishop takes then
these pawns are split pawn takes I can
blockade and now there's some open files
towards their king it should be winning
now my bishop is brought to life let's
give a check and what next 44 seconds
mmm and go here I'm a light square
blockade Knight takes King takes I'm on
the bishop no time for rook takes c4
although there is that move let's pin
that bishop now they could take and then
take on C forwards check but it's not to
work out of this pin I'm gonna go for
that greedy super greedy let's go after
the beep on keep that King on a light
square we don't want any bishop moves
with a check this is helpful
I guess Bishop c7 and I'll get the F for
pawn in the end let's see if I could
convert this
or is it just gonna come down to a rat
race let's cut off the king for starters
yeah I'm thinking it's gonna be a rat
race a mouse race oh my king on b5 his
pawn advances I'll try to get my king
real quick on e4 yeah this saw I could
try for a 485 to undermine the bishop
threatening a 5 which is serious Bishop
III might be a bit short on squares yeah
so now there's a problem
the bishop doesn't have very many
squares let's let's go here with the
check and let's see what the bishop does
trying to kick it off of this diagonal
but I think it has enough squares
especially now that the the King isn't
around hmm it's a time when it should
have been much cleaner in that middle
game could have made some better
decisions g5 was a nice move not too big
a fan with how I played that objectively
this you should be a draw the bishop is
glued in there very nice I can't disrupt
this coordination by black yeah
objectively it's a draw from here but
yeah they played see pretty passive they
allowed a nice build up in the center
for me I guess there's many different
approaches here could have gone with c4
but Bishop e3 can't be so bad actually
you know as soon as I played this in the
game I thought maybe I left a window
open for c5
mm but I do just have c3 keeping my d4
pawn around if there's some added
pressure while I still have enough
support I may want to insert a three
here doing something like Knight d2 can
run into this type of issue and if I'm
backing up with my bishop
oh that Bishop a6 move
but on a c5 c3 knight c6 I can hold off
on the knight move and play a3 because
right now black is threatening to divert
my C pawn away from control of before so
I could have gone with it I guess in
many different ways right around this
point because they weren't really
striking at my center so I had my pick
well they played f5 and now one way or
the other you know one of these bishops
is going to be bad biting on a rock as
it turns out it's the dark square bishop
there's not a not a good way to break
down 'if I've
get that night a kick and maybe simplest
is you know I wasn't expecting this type
of greedy investing the bishop pair and
then grab this pawn type of idea but I
guess the simple approach would be after
after I gave that night a kick to just
take on c5 and then pawn takes if I do
that one move later I mean will happen
in the game because I develop my knight
now the knight is on a six and if I'm
taking the knight is there to recapture
and I'm giving black a square to work
with I have enough control over efore
but you know I could just take and I
probably should have just captured at
this moment on c5 and then brought my
knight in into d6 and I'm not even
having to fight in the slightest to get
upon back it's just material balanced
and I could focus on the positives or I
could focus on the weaknesses a little
bit easier the black weakness is a
little bit easier namely the d6 square
just like I did in the game dropping in
there that would have been a better
approach if I could do it over I would
definitely consider more capturing on c5
before there was a piece there to watch
over it and the thing is is if black
tries to get rid of the one weakness the
deep on there just creating a new
weakness for me to target which may even
be easier to put pressure on so one way
or the other there's going to be a
target within the black structure and
there really isn't a target on White's
end for black to put pressure on so that
would be the main adjustment I think I
would make from a strategic standpoint
that could there will most likely be
other tactical stuff I overlooked but
yeah maybe even here
we did the rook move I think that this
was a possibility yeah yeah they could
have done that one move sooner if I'm
taking the Knights there although no no
I don't have this because they take my
queen with check yeah so this was well
okay I'll excuse me if Bishop takes pawn
now I could take here first
okay yeah but it's this is unnecessary
complications for me to even be down
upon and it shouldn't happen like that
so I hit the rock interesting imbalance
and g5 is a good move I felt the need to
disrupt that strong name
and yeah they have to go with the Queen
exchange she's too much hitting
everything and I wonder what the
computer would say right around here I
probably could have done something
better right around this point yeah
because I was saying for a while you
know doing something like this with my
bishop but as soon as this pawn pushes
you know I got this stuff in fact
probably right now I could do a check
and then line up some kind of a
discovered check although I don't know
if there are I don't know if there's
really a great discovered check you know
they have other pieces on light squares
but I should have at least considered it
this was the first moment where I have
some in intersection square with the
rook and Bishop but takes King up
yeah maybe maybe still just doing this
giving a check and I don't necessarily
have to come over to h1 right away force
the King in the corner before this rook
moves because if I do it one with later
the King's able to step over to FA
so maybe first check and then take and
then step up here I mean for the moment
there isn't a great discover check but
should this night move at least I would
then have something to bite at on e6 so
they might be in a great not really so I
don't even know what to suggest here
there riff - h1 and I guess some kind of
a bishop move I don't know ooh maybe I
could even go for something some kind of
a king Locke idea that's a possibility
yeah but I saw that a little bit too
late and once I did see it you know that
this bishop is controlling h8 I didn't
see a way to control the eighth-ranked
I'm here patrolling the seventh I don't
see how to get here and ya grabbed
another pawn there and this should be a
draw
yeah
they got nothing here they did a good
job there's only one little trick that I
have here threatening a five at this
point if they just if they're careless
and push upon a five and then he's he's
gonna be promoting soon you know Tom
takes I grab the bishop but they
sidestep that little trick could I have
done something better here I wonder Oh
maybe I could have maybe rook here yeah
this is better because what ended up
happening in the game is the bishop was
able to move and throw a punch at my
rook so like this I'm attacking the rook
it's able to move and throw a punch back
I don't want that to happen I want to
when I have a free move like after my
opponent moves their Bishop I want to be
able to go here immediately in put
pressure on b6 and if the bishop has to
come back here to defend then then I
only have a couple squares to try and
control to kick the bishop off of
defending b6 so I think better and of
course we were in bullet mode at this
stage but I'm thinking that rook d1
would have been better instead of ripped
to g3 staying on a light square and if
Bishop e3 I could play rook to e1 my
rook has these two my King has these two
again if Bishop c5 I have a five and in
this case because of the King position
Bishop f2 is out as well because I have
the pin and win of the bishop what could
black have done now maybe maybe they
could do something like this and defend
the pawn like that although this is
pretty passive it is probably still
holding you know even if I get this pawn
maybe the King comes over here and I
could sack my rook for the bishop in
pawn but in the end I only have
a roof on which shouldn't be enough but
anyhow let's have a look at it with
stockfish and see where we can make some
improvements ok stockfish let's see
there's gonna be a pretty significant
advantage i think right around this
middle game point so far that's not
accurate what I just said but I'm I'm
thinking right around here these moves
once I get c4 and off to go with Knight
B for some maybe if 97 then it's a
significant advantage there's a bit of a
jump there give it some time to think
you know I don't know I'm not really a
fan with how the center was undermined
here getting the the bishop on striking
know it is suggesting what I was
pointing out here to take on c5 and now
even target c5 but this isn't this isn't
that great of an advantage something but
hmm Knight c3 Bishop takes f3 oh ok I
guess the idea is to key in on some
square might be to c6 and then there's
an idea by black to play d6 and then all
of a sudden the bishop the knight in the
pond like has the black has a square to
work with yeah and they did try to do
that in the game too but the idea at the
time was to win upon or at least
temporarily yeah and I guess that is an
idea huh if I'm going for this capture
to take out my knight next and then
focus in on this week square in my
position this is a hole on d4 okay
interesting
Knight c3 and now d5 it's suggesting
PAH okay if I take like this
there's no time to recapture here
because I'm on the night okay that would
have been nice because now I'm
threatening d6 and that's like wow
creating a huge wall killing this bishop
yeah that's that's some serious space
advantage if I get that pawn on d6 yeah
d5 would have been a nice find just
right with something normal ish this
file is going to be opened
yeah so I'm down upon but
let's see Knight d6 and I wants to just
go straight away with b3 okay I went
with Knight d6 right away you know one
way I could have viewed this is this
Knight really wants to move doesn't he
so that the rook can see here but if I
keep my knight on b5 they stop a little
bit more work because I will take that
pawn hmm so this is better just to
solidify my structure keep the night
around he still has some nice
flexibility on b5 I may want to just
recoup the the pawn maybe jump in maybe
grab the a pond if black is a little bit
impatient and wants to move the sieve
see Knight right away
b3 noted I committed that night to quick
b3 now night c5 Bishop b2 no I could
just take the bishop huh hmm I thought
the knight would take and then I'm
dropping this guy queen g3 Queen takes
d6 Oh
it's calculated move deeper I'm getting
this Knight back yeah I just saw it as
you know they're gonna get the night I
didn't I didn't take it far enough you
know I didn't see that I have this
follow up of rook takes d4 I trusted my
opponent and I shouldn't have so I just
backed off and went for the rook
so just a hair of an advantage
b4 it likes happy about that
and now queen bee 7mm it's getting
pretty sharp but yeah queen bee 7 Queen
takes b4 and now King eh 1 I don't see
myself playing King h1 at this moment
but yeah if I'm taking here there's
queen c5 and if I'm defending the rook
it's gonna get hit with the e5 and then
the bishop will be hitting it so this is
a tough pin to get out of there at I
went with doubling yeah and I just got a
little bit of an advantage here rook
takes d7 right away hmm what's the big
difference I gave the bishop a kick
first this is a serious advance this is
a winning advantage but g3 first and
then capturing Queen h5 hmm let me just
compare something here suppose I do this
right away and Queen takes d4 oh there's
a mating idea Wow that wasn't on my
radar at all I guess I could slip in
right here playing g3 is helping the
bishop come back to defend the king so
rook on the seventh Queen takes b4 queen
h5 is leading to mate suggested computer
issues just a delay mate Queen e1 but
yeah how do you defend Queen takes h7
successfully you don't yeah Bishop
checking here Queen check got six yeah
and that's the ball game
I didn't see that idea at all so at
least that's the that's what I like to
do with the engine you know you see you
see an evaluation right now where it's
about two and a half with rook takes d7
right away
I played g3 and something drops off and
so you try to work out the differences
and in this case the difference is the
bishop has some defensive role being on
e5
instead of f4 so Bishop e5 in the game
rook takes d7 Queen takes b4 queen h5
still
and now there's Bishop g7 to defend so
there we go
okay the Queen's are off just a hair of
an advantage and is there anything good
with this
h7 square wants to go in for a check
right away
or capture bounced back and forth I
captured now wants to give and throw on
that check King f3 still a bit tricky to
break down because of the dark square
control this is super piece Knight NC 5
mm rook c8 rook e1 look h1 and now rook
c7 yeah there wasn't really a great way
to get at the king okay so I can you f3
any other serious oh there's something
here rook a to g7 ah yeah that would
have been nice with rook to g8 is the
idea I just saw quickly as well let's
let's put them in a pin they'll have to
struggle to get out of that but yeah
this is a killer
it's rip to g8 suggests rook c7 then I'm
picking up the bishop okay I just went
for some pin idea they grab upon and is
this ending winning at all
hmm now I don't think that this is a win
it's probably gonna hold just around
upon Plus but this isn't something that
you can convert
I don't think I missed anything or did I
write around here Brooke d3 okay I
played rugby three bishop g1 rook g3 I
played Bishop h2 rook g2 I gave the
check I should be going rook g2 and then
what's the what's the continuation here
Bishop f4 rookie - yeah the idea here is
to stop the Bishop from guarding the
pawn along this diagonal if he's here
it's a little bit easier that's so many
squares for the bishop to work with and
still defend the pawn okay well I wasn't
going to find this in the game being
both of us had seconds but it was it was
a win at some point let's just see one
of the lines rook f1 let me go you're
further back so rook g2 Bishop e5 or e2
King f5 oh we got some waiting move
ideas rook to be won and finally the
bishop is forced here so now it's a bit
easier king b5 king c6 and then rook to
d1 King he ate and then there's probably
some kind of Zeus fall rook d2 suppose
King here rook d6 there we go
Hahn has to move
rook t5 I could check down this pond
and maybe if the king is flushed far
enough away I do have that idea of
capturing on b6 and then being quick
enough for the paunch promote before the
king could get in the corner okay well
yeah that was the key idea to flush the
bishop off of this diagonal force it to
the shorter diagonal and then work with
finally you know controlling these two
squares somehow okay well interesting
game b6 in reply to one efore or now I
play d4 this one but anyhow feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye